each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I head down a software Q&A session
leading into that I have a few slides
and a little demo I thought I'd do to
get people up to speed so that would be
a good thing to cover well you've all
got your mouth full now get us mostly
kata timewise so I know we have a wide
variation between some people haven't
even looked at the site to get the
software yet to some people are really
up and running and extending it so i'm
going to start from square one and just
make sure everyone's on the same page
about what's what's up with the software
and then we'll we can get more detailed
as we go so first of all what's in the
kit i want to highlight that there's two
distinct pieces so there's the physical
sense can that you get a course from our
lab in cambridge and that also comes
with its own software so there's an
upload wizard if it comes so when you
plug in the sense campus a lot like
plugging in a camera or USB driver
assist what do you want to do with these
things and one of them is i want to
upload sense camp images you want to
make sure you pick that because that
wizard does important things like
turning the images right side up they're
upside down otherwise and badge putting
the right things in the exit header have
also there's an email alias that you can
get ahold of the people developing the
software the hardware for the sims can
directly and don't worry about having to
memorize this or anything this is on the
connect website under I have now a sense
ham faq there then the other part is the
digital memory software and this is
developed by my i would say team but
what happened is my I lost my developer
this is the right right what I most
needed them with all you guys coming on
board I lost instead of this meat so now
developed by mostly him and now
maintained that improved by me is the
other package of software and I want to
highlight that there's these two pieces
because there is some confusion that
there are two cents cam viewers
so if you you could take just the sense
cam and its software and import its
images and it makes a CSV file with all
the sensor data and its viewer will run
straight off of that and you don't have
to use any of our other software that's
all you want to do you just want to use
their viewer you just want to have that
information in there now we have our
viewer and what that uses is the CSV
files are actually imported into the
database as all are the references to
all the images and now you can look the
things date based or sorter view or
however you want whereas the sense cam
the original sin scan software is really
centered around each director each
folder that they create based on a date
so hopefully that will help a little bit
clear up the confusion where you here
which sets cam viewer I'm trying to be
more careful when I mentioned one to let
you know which says can view or do I
mean the Kinect site for those you
haven't been there I I'll show it to you
in a second I'll actually bring up the
web page with it I'm posting the latest
version of my software the digital
memory software are being updating that
at least monthly it's my intention to
keep on doing that so at least every
month does get a new release I think in
May I had three releases of the software
so make sure you keep keep current with
that we're doing lots of bud bug fixes
and improvements to it also there's an
updated version of the fence cam
software from the Cambridge team now I'm
referring to it's actually newer than
what you get on your sense accounts for
even even those of you who just a
receiving since stands now that software
is already outdated and the latest
greatest software is on the connect
website I've also posted their sense cam
demo data so before you even get up and
running and your sense can if you want
to see what it ought to look like you
can there's a bunch of images where I
went out and very carefully didn't shoot
any people's faces so that our lawyers
wouldn't get mad at us and I also
carried a GPS with me so you can import
you know add these photos for your own
collection and if you have the digital
memory software watching that folder
you'll be able to view it in our skin
Sam viewer and even see it on a map and
I'll actually show that to you a little
bit later there's some sample code for
standing the digital memory software how
you can access the database and
information itself and there's some
important tips in particular one thing I
have a be able spend enough time on now
is the whole installation process and
apparently even though it worked for me
trying to install and on top of an
existing installation is running into
problems and then uninstall is not
working there's an article on the
website that it just tells you how you
can work around that forcibly uninstall
things and also forcibly remove any of
the digital memory services so by going
through that we can us and hope
eventually I hope I can figure that out
but installs very time-consuming thing
to try and work out as you may know so
it took me a while to get all that done
so and and I thought also I just make
sure everyone has a nice picture of what
you've got with this software so I'm
just going to run through it quickly and
for those of you who are more or less
familiar and maybe if you are familiar
to go oh I didn't know that little bits
there so running in the background
there's an NTFS file system promotion
service is FS what's the FC so it's
sitting there and you can tell it what
folders you want it to watch in your on
your NTFS file system and it watches the
files and constructor and then the rest
of our software knows about it so it not
only keeps track of all the metadata
about a file it also will try and suck
out a text-only version of us so we can
do full text search based on that
there's also a local web service this is
used by rie explorer for you have an
option when you're in the IE when you're
running in an explore whether you want
to have various query results pop up in
our shell or whether you want to see
them right in IE if you want to see
right in IE what it means is talking to
this little local web service not this
was not a service but it's automatically
installing start group is personal vibe
this is watching the mouse and keyboard
activity that's going on in the machine
and that's that's used also later huh
and there's an Outlook toolbar that you
can fire up it'll watch your emails and
ie toolbar for capturing your web pages
and those have to be enabled you have to
turn them on just the first thing you
want to do to make sure things are up
and running and working this DM info so
this is just intended to give a quick
look at what what do I have running
what's going on so the first thing at
the top they'll tell you what this
software build date was so that would be
helpful and determine what but version
you're running what server you're
pointed at and what database and what
version of the scheme is on there so
again we use them debugging you could
actually point it at a different server
and database I would caution against
that you need to know what you're doing
before you start swapping between
databases but for some of your you know
maybe students are getting more involved
with the code and they're starting to
extend work on their own yep bakken is
very handy to flip between databases and
I know I make copies of little databases
the tests on you work on that and then
you want to get one a new one with a new
name that's fresh because you've mangled
stuff so it's nicely appointed two
different databases there and here are
showing the NTFS sync service and what
folders i'm watching and also what
outlook folders are being watched by the
outlook toolbar and whether the local
web service is running so and as audio
settings thinker by default all our
audio annotation will just use your
default audio and so on and so there's a
way to go in there and double check what
your settings are if you're not getting
audio recorded properly
here's the interface for the ntfs st.
controller itself so you can come in and
click Add initially this will be empty
it just because it's running doesn't
mean it's watching anything so when you
first start it up you go hey where my
files there won't be any files until you
tell the system watch these folders and
then they'll know about your files or
folders so you take you say a did you
come to watch the folder and down below
that you can just see what's happening
so it it takes a fair while first testo
to walk the tree and know what all the
files are on the basic metadata and then
it's going to go back and promote the
files is called so it's going to go into
images and try and bring out information
from the exit header it's going to go to
documents and suck out text so that we
get the full text search and so on so it
takes a while on the first pass to suck
it all through it after that if you
start this up you see it doesn't happen
that often oh also there's a sense cam
imports program with the digital memory
software and this is to take that comma
separated file and suck that information
into the database into a table you can
run that if you want to point it at one
of these CSV files but you don't have to
if you've got your ntfs sync controller
watching the folder that you sent scam
photos go into and in its csv file it
will automatically get imported into the
database but since we thought what
people might not be watching that folder
we want to make it manually available
also oh and as far as where since cam
photos go the Cambridge team right now
you don't have a choice about where
they're being put from their softer but
if you look at the sense camp faq on the
connect website there's information
there about a registry key that you can
change to have it put in another
location so you can have a footwear you
know my photos or wherever you want this
actually reminds me that I promised to
show you the Connect website and I
didn't so let's let's go back to that
so connect up microsoft com for those of
you who have been here you know that you
have to have a passport for your email
address i'm using my personal one here
to double check them up anything just
because I got a Microsoft address and
then under my participation he
potentially could be using this for a
bunch of different beta program so you
see under my participation is the
digital memories program and then here
there's some announcements we've got
here's the FAQ that I was telling you
about over on the side by the way all
this is generic to connect so if you
click on these ones here you end up back
out if sort of the main connect site
outside the digital memories these are
memories in particular gear we have in
addition to this main page with some
links and announcements and one not
there's also the downloads page and here
you'll see the June twentieth release of
the digital memory software there's our
list of the changes in the previous
updates the latest sense cam software
the sample and so on so that's the
Connect website let's hear five lawd
viewers a quick way to see what personal
by blogger is recording for you so this
is showing the time and key and most
activity and what window is in the
foreground and the what was in its title
and so on and we tried it if we can
figure out what documents being used
alright so now I thought I'd run through
a little demo of a few features did
because I thought did you know that you
can do this you might not be aware and
it'll just help give you a picture of
more things in the software so in
internet explorer with our toolbar here
what one thing you can do is there's
some built-in queries so I can say what
pages of mice did I look at today and
this here seats localhost 50-50 that's
that local web service i was talking
and so here is showing a bunch of pages
that I've looked at so i could go and
you go look at the archived version of
this page and when i do and we have a
little header here saying that it was
when it was archived and so on you can
go out to the version on the web here's
the captured version page and I can also
see the previous page that I looked at
just before I looked at this one and the
page that I looked at this next we have
the same option here to go to the
previous or next and I can click on that
so you can sort of go back to your
history and then we're too good now you
can go back back and forth the in
history and walk through replay what you
did with your web pages we also have
besides you can search the msn or
digital memories you can run full-text
searches or we can look at these
predefined ones i can look at all the
web pages i've ever annotated all the
ones that are marked with the thumbs up
or here just another interesting one
looking at the frequency but when you
access things and saying I'm determining
these are essentially I think these are
your favorites automatically for you so
just thought you might not know that's
there when you get into outlook so we
were just talking about this a little
while ago so I'm going to remember to
talk about settings here there's there's
a status indication that look feel bar
what is doing right now so it's idle
right now I can click this and actually
see detailed message from what's going
on so sometimes you wonder what's this
thing doing and you might find out oh
it's standing some folder a lot so I
need to change my settings on that and
in the options you go in and you you set
that file say okay yeah I want to be
keeping track of the email in this
folder and when you click on the
settings it'll say how often do you do
think so i can say all right did some
default ones like well this is on my
extensive or so this is saying a quick
sync every 15 minutes in a full sync
every five hours or i can set it
whatever I want so i can say well i want
a quick sync ever so many minutes in a
full sync every three days what whatever
you like there you can also say queue up
a full sync right now I want one right
now so what can happen there is that you
know maybe you get your studies long so
you're scanning it too often the idea is
that your PST files of archives you just
want to scan it once you just queue a
full sync to scan at one time and that's
it the difference between the Quick Sync
and the full sync is unfortunately
outlook does it notify us about
deletions so we're keeping track with
our Quick Sync we're keeping track of
everything pretty well but we don't know
stuff that you've deleted so everyone's
long we have to go through and rescan to
find out what's gone so unfortunately
that's just part of the outlook object
model for us so that's the difference
between the Quick Sync and the full sync
so then you need to sort eat and it
depends on the on the folder so the some
that are never scanned at all they don't
have to so it's your archive so that's
why not if you have something where
you're much so the way I do it my really
old archives like I have one there
that's you know from 2000 is never going
to change so I scanned it once and
that's it my most recent archive I tell
it to scan every couple of days and then
my actual exchange server I'm telling it
do the quick sync all the time and do a
full sync every couple of hours also
when it when it starts up it won't start
but with a real problem we have is we'd
launch out looking right away start
grinding away and so right now the code
should be set so shouldn't do that what
it starts up it should say well if you
only ask for quick sync every 10 minutes
then you ought to be able to live
without me syncing for the first Timothy
story up but you do something and you
also have this just pause so if you give
it is get in your way when it's not idle
hear this pause button will be active
you can click pause and it'll stop what
it's doing so you're not getting that
bog down by it there also search wise so
let's just look for Allen here has doing
it before by default when I do a search
there's this custom
custom dialogue comes up the nice thing
about it is it's really fast actually
it's not as fast as it seems it feels
really fast because it gives u partial
results as it go so it's a real
feel-good kind of result however there's
not a lot of power from this point in I
can't pivot and narrow and do all the
things that I can with the shell so if
if you find that you want to do that
back any options under search you could
say lost external application it should
be set with a correct go picture for the
shell and leave in some work here now so
now that I kicked that that should go
launch our shell yeah and I'll bring it
up there so then you can do the and of
course it feels much slower is the
downside there we go so it's a trade-off
there between you what you want to do
with outlook okay so i also want to show
you my the other version of the sense
cam viewer so here is the digital
memories since cam viewer with a
different resolution here now ah-ha-ha
coalition refresh it i guess it's
confusing on it's not robust to resize
terrible start that up again so if you
with this demo day i initially with the
demo day i guess now right now we'll be
loading the most recent day is why
what's slow on the start and i'm going
to show you the demo date a second by
kissimmee as will show you whatever i
got from the last day of faculty summit
here as well so here we go i'm still
hiding the bottom line oh well so just a
couple of things that i want to point
out for narrowing in on the actual
sensor data it so up at the top here
when you're right click you can see what
the different lines are different values
for them the color coding
and this is a double ended slider this
is we had I had an intern from
University of Maryland I I really like
this for how you essentially zoom and
pan through the it shows you where
you're at in the time scale any place I
click on here will jump to that to the
photo nearest to that in time so you
don't have to pick where there's an
actual photo and soon campus rep quite
so oh yeah this is from wandering around
the faculty summit and if you load our
sample data I believe it's March
seventeenth and what's doing is it look
it's actually reading in all the photos
that we can do that quick reply fair so
this is what you'll get so if you load
in if you download the zip file and
unpack it into where our NT fencing that
controller is watching a folder you'll
get this data and you'll get this is
your data points I am still reading them
and you get these other photos too so
there we go actually you get almost all
these photos so I I stripped up the
shots of faces in it so you won't get
that one but you'll get a bunch of these
other ones here so we'll walk down by
Columbia River and I had with my son
little while ago and you'll also be able
to see that here it is on the trip
replay so this is the GPS coordinates of
everything in that walk and we can also
animate well I have more here than the
walk I should say so this is starting
out at our hotel and we go down and here
we are walking along the lake
all right well if you're going to still
running and then you're going to see it
go much faster because we get back in
the car and go for a little Drive across
the bridge and around there we go and
one more thing you might not know is
they're back in the shell here I want to
show you here is if you once you get
into photos you will get location as one
of the options for how you can filter
and in the location you can zoom in on
an area and so I'm going to this is from
Hawaii I just had a vacation in a while
going to zoom in a little tighter here
back much tighter and once I get down to
where the level i want i can say apply
and now it's only going to show me
photos from that area and the reason we
have the apply button we don't do
automatically is because the other thing
i can do is i can i can get rid of using
this map so now I'm saying tell me all
about all photos you go back by date
you
to what's wrong here oh I get this start
over again it up so I want and we don't
okay so let's look at only pictures from
june and ok here we go so that's fine so
here's some pictures now if i go to
location I can actually I want it even
tighter I can actually take a photo here
and drag and drop and say that's its
location so you can assign locations
using the map in the shell here if you
have photos that you didn't have a gps
with you can also if you were carrying a
GPS you can also use a GPS import tool
and will automatically location snap the
photos you know it's a little bit of an
obscure once I thought you might not be
aware that one other thing that I hope
will work here but being running the
vibe blogger yes i have so go I want web
pages from
today and because of what we're
capturing with the web pages were pretty
good I think with google and msn search
we're picking up search terms so let's
see if this is working yeah so here's
search terms that i use today so you can
find pages that were consequence of that
search and also if you look in detail
view there's a whole lot of attributes
oh by the way you can change also
decides this or so it's handy with the
map to make it a lot wider we have a
whole bunch of fields and you can turn
on and off the columns and detail view
for all the different types so all items
have certain attributes but web pages
have special attributes and including i
think its time which is the time on the
web page so let's see if that's all
right okay so that didn't get populate
for some reason this but ought to when
you're running personal vibe it ought to
be populating the time that you actually
spent on the web page so you can sort by
that so I have to figure out why that
wasn't running for me then okay so
that's got some things that you might
not have known that you can do and then
the award for the first new item type
goes to Michael schockner from you at
UNC who went he went he was the first
guy to actually say I want my own new
item type I just want to let you know
you really can do this so we have
instructions it's in the in the
documentation that you get with the
software he followed it and I want you
to you know parse this right now but
just understands this is some sequel
that you write a lot of its
auto-generated from sequel server where
you say you don't give me you know the
creation of my new table or whatever and
you do things in the right sequence and
your items will be there that just
automatically appear in the shell I'm
working now on code so that they'll also
appear in the list of the different
types when you break down by type so
that's not there yet but you can see
them if you can detail via search by
today you'll see your item
you can do full text search on them so
it's great so that's all working so now
that everyone's finished eating I'm
going to ask you some questions here is
anyone planning on extending the shell
with a new visualization because I I'm
Way behind on my promise instructions on
how to do that and I wanted to know is
anyone's is dying for that should i put
no okay good so it's easier than yes we
would I will live the idea is it should
be pretty easy so there be instructions
above there be a base class that you'd
inherit from and c-sharp essentially and
then make sure you fill in certain
methods so you have to respond to things
be Phillips you you have to know all a
filter has changed or there's a nuclear
or something like that you need to do
something new for you to populate your
your results is basically what it is and
knowing where to go in the database so
we have a we have a particular method of
the shell is doing a synchronous queries
and everything for you so and then at
certain point says okay it's time for
you to render your results and it'll
tell you there's a particular table and
here's the ID of the query result you go
off on you you look through the table
you find out here's all the items and
then it's up to you to render them
however you want so to define and I have
to give them a list of things that would
be helpful to do with this but I don't
to know that it's feasible to do this in
oversea yeah it certainly could
certainly would be the the thing I just
I'm a little behind because as I said I
lost my dad and we actually we had a
different shell before at but we were
using a third-party library for our
windowing system that our lawyers
wouldn't let us give to you guys so
we're redoing this now and I haven't got
quite up to speed on this but the idea
is if you if you inherit for this base
class and fill in the blanks and you
just drop your dll in the right
directory it should just appear in the
shelf so
yeah it should be feasel and as far as
how much time it takes them then it's
not really fitting into our it's how
much how wild they want to go with what
the visualization is like so I know our
developers there's one there's a
timeline to in the shell I guess I'm not
running it now but there's two different
timelines and so the one will drop down
list that was created by one of our
developers up here Redmond who just
wanted to try it out and he is the
piccolo to a kit from Maryland and
created that in like a week probably
less he was being a part time you know
so it yeah it is quick and easy well
tell you what if if you decide you're
serious let me know because it's just a
matter of priorities for me so I have
other requests for software features and
I haven't got around to that so if
someone wants that by a certain time
please let me know and I'll I'll make
sure I come through with that second
question for you we want to hold another
workshop for the final results so a lot
of this was preliminary discussion we'd
love to get everyone back together again
to say hey how did it go but what did we
finally learn from all this when should
we do that and I also this question is
one day enough I think the answer is no
already but I feedback from anyone but
when would be a good time if do we need
to wait another year or can we talk
another plans but you want to do a few
red minted wow so that's the option so
we could wait a full year and tag it on
faculty summit again I could try and you
know or we could we can do it as its own
state I think probably what's going
multi-day it could almost be its own
event they thinks on yet what if you run
longer I think would be able to okay
nobody ha ha power so I fazila presume
we had everyone that's 14 group to half
hour each so that's seven hours of just
present
cook it welcomes race against things
like the business the interaction outfit
puffy it right having our lunch on my
knees here yeah I would have the 32 days
treating ya the rest carpe I i did was
kind of like what you're suggesting
kairos is jam-packed with presentations
and then everyone flew home and said you
know we never got to talk to each other
so i think it does help the schedule at
in I this should have been a really easy
day to fit in as surprise me of how
tight it is even with people this thing
well here's what I think I'm going to
work on someone presentations yeah
actually have some video clips showing
what you've done and that would really
add to it yeah that's great um but in
terms of win the whole that what I'm
wondering is how soon would be too soon
so I know some of you are waiting we're
waiting you've got to have that sense
cam if we said okay next februari we
want to hold the event would you say oh
no that's too soon i need another four
months to work on it or what but
actually what I take sort of a pole here
so who would be happy with safe februari
would be ready to go by then no not good
Oh occasion okay but I met knocker
difficult problem approximately so I'm
not Jan you Ares competitive who want
who would rather wait a year who needs
another year to show us something
another way to look like in the academic
record some April had a chance
so my suggestion is that you think about
the joint companies and digital
libraries which is an improving next
summer what what and what is going
company when its allies that are I think
it's Joo Joon all right so we can
infiltrate the conference we could have
the tutorial on since can the first day
we could have things in the poster
session we can have a two-day workshop
at the end panel we proposal
logistically it's hard for us to do
conferences that they get too close to
the faculty summit someplace else this
is jun 17 and then we have felt worried
summertime is Jim full with other
academic conferences like siggraph
things that just impact how we are able
to do things but that is a reasonable
suggestion that weakness so we could
piggyback on a conference in June yep if
we're way for their head we'd be trying
to get you all out to carpe in October
but I sure that's a little bit quick a
few of you are coming I know Santa
Barbara and then it's too late following
that but so what I'm hearing those
sometime between say April and June the
next year ok well let's follow this up
with email and people can think about it
and respond more give us more specific
suggestions by just want to get a feel
for you should I be thinking five months
out of year will be thinking you're out
but I think I'll be really exciting to
say okay this is the consequence of all
the work is done here and what we got
out of them telling you there's a
possibility of them involving from the
doctoral students who are working on art
projects go down a lot of us feel like a
really important
so that double maybe triple the size of
the event so that's a question on John's
ability to think about it so but well
this isn't an officer yeah the mother's
voice is my gear yeah the discussion
when the whole cumin opened a fight
that's perfect well I mean that sounds
fun if everyone was here with the grass
boy we'd have 30 or 40 people here and
then we'd almost certainly want to do it
here just a lot district reasons right
if you hardly have that mean people at
different city were different from here
we have room technology though you try
and write and unless it really unless
someone wants to actually open it up at
yeah I guess it difficult a problem with
the other conference at is that you know
it's at an open workshop or you know
here we're saying we want we want to
hear a presentation by everyone who and
what it's not open we're not refereeing
or anything like that or do present
great you're coming here for the
challenge of doing it all for it through
the part of the film and we definitely
wanna film it that's true you can go
anywhere he's voting for the Bahamas all
right all right this is that you try to
involve graduate students and it's
totals it wasn't
for us on the righteous to do now so
we've got a second please to go to prove
over in my big mention you mentioned
that there was a note that was a
personal memories workshop at JC here
sooner this year has a first management
I owe you a personal digital library
workshop I mean you could propose it
among ourselves and if it's accepted
that we can run it however what I fear
isn't what it's like there isn't the
ideal the way your proposal usually sent
to me is hey since you decide to have
this much of this carpet you also send
my PhD students to the conference I
think this up in Islam have apple have
empty and I have some funding I'm
funding the students at the Doppler
consortium JC yeah there's the real
reason about that assertion there but
there's a committee depicts the students
who go to that so I can't guarantee that
how many come from from this group that
I can provide some funny for those
problems were selected
cool just think about it maybe raise it
again at dinner yeah we have to pick
that up again what else that we're here
what's the most important feature
missing from the software right now
requests anybody want things bumped up
my priority list well my my main
suggestion is that this be integrated
with the professed top search support
that's being provided separately that
what do you mean by integrated so to be
frank it's almost unusable to the tube
to work with this for accessing my mail
insertion files and stuff where is the
desktop system and Microsoft provides
typically is sorry Xbox career is the
thing off a dent voters if you type of
knowing the desktop search that
Microsoft shifts uses just it there's no
database there for them so they don't
have types links extended mated metadata
you can't extend the system suit has
very slow with the Missouri to do that
yeah but if they you have to hack it to
extend it is the problem so it is
exactly the trade-off between Sue's
approach on mine and I I'm a big
fantasies work and I want her to do what
she does because it can it can ship much
faster the idea is this is a platform
this a little further out and research
you you can do more with it so maybe if
you if you have specific suggestions
about what's making it not usable enough
for you you know let me let me go at it
okay look you know my dear student would
disagree with you he really like to be
able to add integrate what we do with
them
with the soccer and there's a way to do
that I'm keeping all right so I actually
getting called the source code either
that were there are some well-defined if
I interface you can plug in right
cependant and the only interface we have
now so you can add types you can plug in
visualizations to the shell or else you
guys start writing your own ass it is
essentially at so you're saying you'd
actually like to offer the software so
that's absolutely open sir and Julie
versus the right kind of date because I
had one of high students as an intern I
guess this year goes so now and them so
he knows the software very wealthy I a
second day because you know I put my
name whatever you need some percentage
and also possible to to make happy
components sort of configurable
configurable component like the web and
email capture well it might be I'd like
to capture into my data instead of to do
my life pains so then again i can save
it through only web and what's in your
database doesn't mean I because I've
been developing from from scratch in
your business yeah if I could
configuration I can save it to my food
my health is one of the inside of my
life because I kind of using this
point is I need much more flexibility
for that if I can be great okay well we
should talk about Davis is particular
but you'd like to modify the source also
so that's the takeaway from that power
over us adding stuff do the shell is it
possible for you to provide components
that you're using your shell
can plug into our application because
because I think with what might happen
is an each one of us we have very
specialized needs but I'd be much easier
for us to develop our own disposition
but you use all the stuff that you have
because you have some really cool stuff
so that I think that's the kind of game
is what I meant you can provide
components of different aspects to your
shell I think I canticle for it or not
the water that might get a good thing
about this because this type of thing
would be you know we add again we also
released there's a place you know from
the rest of the data can also use yeah
well that would be very nice so where
would become a consortium type of people
right you right I think that would be
great so I'm excited to hear that
interest I did I didn't know if there
would be and also because I'm just me
now you know people who see some little
feature that they really want to have to
just write it and we'd have it so I
think that's something we should follow
up Sean insurance what legal says about
how we think that you guys course I have
the best things just go all the way to
stores because actually he could take me
a couple of months to try and packaged
up you know new interfaces and things
like that whereas I could just open up
the source code and then it's just a
matter of explaining things so so you
are here engineer my recommendation
would be we get some of their time to
clean it up a bit and then once it's
cleaned up and release the source of the
group so they install and all that stuff
gets tricked good you want to have a
repository to check in no let's say that
because good and it'll be he's he want
to be here together then I want to check
in other people can use disorders and do
other things right
because well I'll take that one off line
if anyone has experienced with that with
the sharing sources stuff and some tips
for me on that as I get into this please
grab me in the coffee break or something
them and let me know you need a been
doing I don't use the sword from
Congress did you did huh there's a model
to come yeah that's right windows right
our Katie's figured out how to give the
windows sauce so you can give that
you've any night okay well that's um I
suppose I think this is going to feature
where where people could build a
low-level backbone and might be asking
too much but uh but one thing what it's
the annotation the people annotating
their document there's no way for them
to look and get sort of a keyword list
of concepts they've used for four years
before and so some kind of feature we
found something like that might be
really useful for students were working
keep a few days just a alphabetical
keyword list you know now what do you
think the keywords should actually
something distinct from I wish now I'd
never used the word annotation I should
have call it comment so a lot of mine
are super long they're very different
from the kind of keywords using Flickr
or something like that would you like to
see keywords as a separate supported
feature is that what you're saying
the imitation description and here is
the key concept it alone right yeah and
I have to say I apologize for how little
sanitation's are even exposed in our
shell so to give you a little history on
this in our previous shell I loved it
but comments were that it was like
flying a 747 it fears that once you're
familiar with these concepts is really
nice when you click on an item to see
everything about it so I have a little
panel that show me everything is linked
to it all the annotations and you kind
of the end even before you click on you
see counts of how many there are and you
really knew whether we're clicking on
but for the for the newbie who walks up
there they go all is what it looks like
developer studio so you have like 10
pains open it looks very intimidating
but it's also very powerful so on the
other hand are shell now is a lot
simpler but you go oh does this thing
have annotation out if you have to click
and say show me link items and it's kind
of a kind of a downer have you
learning my pages it's not it doesn't
take advantage of metadata that might
already be assisting on these documents
although the problem is allows consent
metadata is it's really bad now I was
more document properties well I don't
know you know I would sequin sooo mad
about this you know sometimes the
metadata the phone like a word document
it completely wrong it's you know
whoever whoever worked in the word
microsoft / for me but brought it but
they're me they're me it just made it
something to keep yeah I think that's
your right I mean technically we should
promote that and I think what you're
describing is a chicken or the egg kind
of thing because why is there all this
crummy metadata in a lot of these well
where would you ever use that metadata
there's no there's no real use for it
now whereas if it was promoted into the
shell and you could actually search and
sort based on it hey then then it would
be worthwhile entering who the author of
a document is still we probably have too
small or user community to really tip
tip over in that but in principle what
you saying i think is right